foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalists podcast where we discuss
what it means to live a meaningful life
with less my name is Joshua Fields
Milburn and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and
together we are the minimalists we're
here with malabama hi everybody C.K
Coleman is actually gone this week he's
speaking in a few schools in
Pennsylvania and Texas showing them what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less but don't worry he'll be back with
us next week we've got the rest of our
team in the studio here today and coming
up on this free public minimal episode
we're talking to an aspiring minimalist
about her struggles with career clutter
we also have an outstanding lightning
round segment a live stream question and
a listener tip for you you can check out
the full two hour maximal edition of
episode 380 where we answer four times
the questions and we dive deep into
several simple living segments that
private podcast episode is out right now
at patreon.com
the minimalists your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube channel 100
advertisement free because
say it with me y'all
advertisements suck
yes they do let's start with our callers
y'all if you have a question or comment
for our podcast give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at themalists.com our first
question today is from Grace
my name is Grace and I live in Bedford
in the UK I am 37 years old and I am an
aspiring minimalist I've decluttered the
kitchen drawers got rid of over half of
my wardrobe and I love enjoying the
simple things in life especially
spending time with my fiance and dog
life at home is great my work life
however is not so easy to minimalize
I left school at 18 to be a professional
dancer I had danced my whole life and so
this was a dream come true I spent a
good few years doing this until I hit my
mid-20s and decided I should become more
adult so I quit dancing and started
working in retail and bought flat at the
same time I quickly worked my way up
moved to London and became a stylist in
a flagship store then got a spot on a
head office display team creating window
installations for stores around the
world I loved the creative side of it
but I didn't enjoy the consumerism part
of it I think this is where minimalism
had planted its seed in me
at the same time as working in retail I
had set up a market store to make ends
meet selling scones every weekend the
scones took off and long story short I
landed a book deal amazing however over
time I couldn't keep up these two jobs
and in the end retail won out the scones
just didn't make enough money for me to
live on so I had to put them to bed at
that point then I randomly made friends
with a burlesque performer one evening
she invited me to watch a show of hers
so I went along I was sold the next day
I signed up to a course and it set me on
fire my old passion for dance was
reignited I got lucky and got offered
spots with established burlesque
producers which I'm still doing now
every so often I managed to leave retail
and go self-employed with the burlesque
but not for long venues were closing
down and gigs became less frequent so I
had to find something else in between a
few scon orders and dog walking for a
couple of years I decided to go to
university I had never gone after
leaving school and so I thought why not
now I got a spot in a top Arts
University which I graduated from last
summer I loved my time there I learned
so much from filmmaking to costume
making which I now also do for burlesque
performers as well as myself and also
producing after I graduated I got a job
freelancing as a creative producer for
an entertainment agency I'm due to
finish there at the end of March this
year I still do baking demos during the
summer months and added a yoga teacher
training course during lockdown during a
summer in between the first and second
year at Uni so I sometimes though now
rarely run yoga classes as well I've
been so incredibly Lucky in my life with
all of these opportunities and I am
passionate about them all I feel that
the Universe has given me gifts of which
I cannot ignore and therefore not let go
of I am now stuck in not being able to
choose which ones I should focus more on
than others I cannot keep them all up as
I get ill quite often due to trying to
balance everything and always failing at
being really good at any one thing I
feel like a jack of all trades master of
none I understand how privileged I sound
with all of this and how lucky I am and
have been I know I will always be okay
with finding work and so this is an
issue that cannot be compared to other
people's actual problems how do I
simplify career clutter and find peace
in what I do for a living
we're getting married soon hopefully
this year and if I'm even luckier and
able to have a family of my own I want
to be a mother who lives by example and
by sharing my values with my children
compassion creativity and Community I do
not want to be this flustered
semi-failing lack of self-belief woman
who can't seem to focus so Grace
you have a lot of career clutter that
you've accumulated over the course of 37
years and it's much like the material
clutter that we often create it doesn't
happen overnight it's not like you woke
up one day and said all right I'm gonna
try out retail and I'm gonna write a
book and do this uh was it sconces
scones scones oh she was making scones
okay delicious yes and you got a book
deal based on the scones and then the
dancing and burlesque and you're
self-employed in your dog walking and
then you decided to do yoga teacher
training and then you wanted to go to
university and all those things can be
awesome and realizing that you can do
any of those things Grace you are
infinite yeah and you it's capable you
you are infinite and it is possible that
you can do anything that you want to do
you just have to look inside you and
figure out what am I actually motivated
to do because many of these things you
may be inspired by someone else and when
someone inspires you what happens you
aspire to do the thing that they do even
though you may not have the internal
motivation to actually do it so I
wouldn't let the aspiration she even
mentioned being an aspirational
minimalist I wouldn't allow the
aspiration to get in the way of my own
internal motivation because as soon as
we do that now we're controlled by
someone else's inspiration someone else
really wants to write a book or make
scones or be a yoga teacher and if you
want to do those things great you can
follow that motivation in that direction
and just because you do it for a period
of time doesn't mean you'll want to do
it in perpetuity and that's okay as well
we don't have to continue to hold on to
those things and make them part of our
identity that's identity clutter on top
of the career clutter and I think those
two things are very well linked right I
am this person this is who I am I'm a
yoga teacher I am an author I am a dog
walker whatever it might be it's funny
though I notice with my daughter she's
nine years old and she started a dog
walking business in our neighborhood
it's called Paul's p-a-w-s uh pretty
awesome walking service that's so cool
and she's doing it to save up money
because eventually someday in the
distant future she wants to buy a horse
that's that's so cool isn't that awesome
yeah it really is the the weird thing is
where we live in Ojai the animal shelter
has horses in addition to dogs and cats
and lizards and other things and you can
buy a horse for like 200 bucks there but
she doesn't realize that beyond that you
also have to pay to take care of it and
feed it and all the time and attention
that goes into it as well why am I
bringing this up because with Grace yes
buying the horse or getting in the
career that you want might sound good
but the are you also motivated to do all
of the things beneath the surface to
take care of the horse or to perpetuate
the career in a way that is continuing
to be satisfying and fulfilling for you
because if you're not and you're simply
following someone else's path you I'm
inspired by someone else I'm inspired by
that yoga teacher okay great but if you
don't want to be a yoga teacher now all
of a sudden needing to be the yoga
teacher will control you we're going to
talk about this a little bit later on
the private podcast Ryan a man who needs
nothing
cannot be controlled hmm
because if you need money
well then now you're controlled by money
and the means to make the money
if you need love well now you're
controlled by the people
whom you believe can dispense love to
you if you need a possession that
possession becomes a prison I would even
take this farther and say if you want
these things deeply
they begin to control you that's not a
bad thing morally I want to be clear
about that in fact if you have a deep
compelling desire to do something
whatever it is out of all of these
things you've tried or maybe even
something else that you are considering
trying if you have a deep compelling
desire it will control you and that's
okay you can let it control you for me
writing has been the thing that controls
me I have a deep compelling desire and
it controls me it tells me to get up
early every morning and sit in the chair
for at least an hour a day and I talk to
my how to write better writing students
about this but if they're not compelled
to write then certainly I wouldn't say
well you still have to do the writing no
if there's something that is a deep
compulsion that you're willing to devote
yourself to
that can be beautiful but if it controls
you to the extent that it makes you
miserable then it's someone else's dream
that is controlling you one last thing
I'll say here Ryan she said I don't know
which ones to choose and that
presupposes you should pick of the 15
things you want to do just pick half of
them so I'll pick seven you know I'll
take eight you know just because I
really like these eight and then I'll do
all eight of these things really poorly
and wonder why I'm not getting anywhere
with them right and I found in my own
life the thing to do with career clutter
is to what simplify to let go in fact if
you name those 15 things that you find
to be mildly compelling and then you
rank order them and sometimes you're
just gonna have to guess I don't know I
really like these two things I don't
know number one number two they're
interchangeable wonderful but if you
rank order them and you have the top 15
take that bottom 14 lock them in a
drawer somewhere and say no no no no
because unless that first thing is a
hell yeah for you
then you're just gonna have a bunch of
lukewarm yeses yes to this yes to this
yes to this yes to this and you're gonna
end up not being Satisfied by any of
those things it's like whenever I go to
a tapas restaurant
I'm like I was a little bit of this a
little bit of that a little bit of that
and the truth is yes I can fill up on
those things but imagine if I just
brought you a crumb of each item
are you gonna feel satisfied are you
going to feel full fulfilled no of
course not it doesn't mean you can't
approach those things later in the
future but until the one thing becomes a
hell yeah still becomes the priority
not priorities there's no such thing as
priorities priority means the first
thing whatever is the priority that is
the hell yes for you and everything else
isn't just a no Grace
it's a hell no
um
yeah man um yeah Grace is out here
living life getting all the flavors I
love what you talked about her being
infinite
um because yeah she can do anything she
wants and man she is uh you know kind of
uh blessed lucky fortunate whatever you
want to call it to have all of these
different passions or these these
different interests because a lot of
people
um it's hard for them to find one thing
that kind of motivates them you know
there's no right answer here right like
Grace if she wants to continue to do all
these 15 things that's okay there's
nothing wrong with that
um also I want to say there's nothing
wrong with how you feel Grace you know
it's you you can't help how you feel
you're allowed to feel however you feel
it doesn't make you wrong because I used
to beat myself up in the corporate world
when I was miserable and I'm like oh I'm
so ungrateful I just take all this for
granted people would kill to be in this
position and here I am complaining about
it and uh yeah it took me a while to
realize like hey it's it's okay to not
be happy with something even though
someone is looking at your life saying
well you should be happy because you
know you have what I have so don't put
yourself up there Grace man I I like the
list idea
um the other thing too is you could just
like write these on little pieces of
paper put them in a bucket and you go to
pick one but like as soon as you go to
pick one usually there is a overwhelming
desire for one particular thing to be on
that piece of paper when you look at it
and that's that's kind of the hell yes
that would that would be the way to
I don't know kind of start sorting
through these the the thing that I would
two things I would I would uh do if I
was in Grace's shoes here I would
first off I would get really really
clear on what my values are
and
uh you can do that with our values
worksheet uh the minimalists.com forward
slash v as in value as in values and uh
what this does even if you just fill out
the foundational values what it does is
it will help guide these different
interests because regardless of your
interests uh if you're doing something
that takes away or dismisses one of
these foundational values let alone the
structural values and the surface values
um
then then that's where I would that's
where I would be cautious because I know
like with the corporate world you know
five percent of it ten percent of it was
managing people and like really helping
people get better at their job and I
love that but ninety percent of it was
soul-crushing um so um yeah start with
your start with your values uh and then
the other thing too is you know you talk
about the horse
and the values will help you get to this
but what's your horse Grace yeah like
what are you working for right like what
is your ultimate end goal if it's to
make money which I think that is uh
probably not the right goal it's
probably not good to put money in the
driver's seat it's certainly in the
vehicle
um but if it's money then okay just go
for what's gonna make you the most money
yeah if it's uh you know contentment if
it's making room for hobbies then uh
then then then you know move towards
that but Grace you've got to get clear
on what you want what that horse is for
you and to get clear on that
you got to start with you got to start
with your values
um Chris got a lot of hobbies that's
cool it's not a big deal maybe you know
if there's one thing that you can do
that is really paying the bills and
giving you the freedom to do these other
Hobbies then that's
yeah that's an option I mean I snowboard
I mountain bike I long board I have a
wakeboard in a long time I have a water
board ever
that one time in college
um but you know I have these hobbies
that I probably do
you know a handful of times a year
um and that's okay I don't I don't take
on any more Hobbies because I don't have
room for any more
um hobby accoutrement
but it's okay to have hobbies Grace you
got a good problem so yeah don't beat
yourself up figure out what that horse
is get clear in your values
um I think that'll help guide you I want
to get clear about the problem though
because I think you're bringing up a
really great Point Ryan because there
are a couple things a couple directions
I can go first off I'll say that values
worksheet that Ryan mentioned it's free
you can download it for free and you can
get clear on what your different types
of values are what drives you what
compels you and from that you can decide
what you want to become devoted to there
was an exercise you mentioned about
putting those 15 items into a bucket or
a hat and just drawing out one and
saying before you even pull it out oh
what's the one I hope for if that's not
clear to you one thing that's worked
well for me is as soon as I reach in
there I hope I don't pull this one out
oh you can start Crossing stuff off yeah
that way you know like ah yes I know I
could be a yoga teacher but it's not
actually for me and you can cross them
off before even pulling them out at that
point yeah what what is your heart
telling you in that moment yes and Grace
it seems to me like you've gotten pretty
clear about your gratitude you've even
said that well I know this sounds like
an incredibly privileged problem as our
friend TK Coleman would say Your
Privilege is irrelevant in an instance
like this because some problems yes
feelings or feelings yeah and and so yes
you have a problem here as Ryan
illuminated having a bunch of hobbies is
not a problem however it's a problem for
Grace because they're stressing her out
and she feels listless
directionless and she wants to regain
some of that direction and the way you
do that is by getting hyper hyper
focused I'm not telling you you should
do that but I know the way to find the
direction in which I want to travel is
simply focusing on the thing that is
most compelling and everything else sort
of Falls by the wayside doesn't mean you
can't pick them back up but you're gonna
have to set a few things down to
eliminate that career clutter that's
getting in the way yeah I love where
you're talking about uh the compelling
aspect of it here like doing something
that you can't not do like you know when
it comes to Passion we always talk about
um what's my passion hey what's your
passion uh I want to have a passion I
can't find my passion like it's this
ownership thing and you know you can't
possess a passion but a passion can't
possess you so the question is is which
of those Hobbies possess you yes yeah
and she said she feels really lucky
that's a position of gratitude tap into
that luck what do you feel most lucky
about
oh because when I feel really lucky I
feel what Carefree I feel light I feel
joyous I feel overwhelmed with gratitude
not prescriptively because it's not
about you just need to be grateful Grace
no you already have that gratitude let's
uncover it together
I want to send you a copy grace of our
book everything that remains Ryan and I
wrote this book almost a decade ago now
Ryan and it was really about walking
away from a bunch of things that were
yeses but they weren't hell yeses for us
they were lukewarm yeses they're like I
guess I'll try that out and we decided
hmm I need to set some of those down I
need to make room
for hell yeah so I'm gonna send you a
copy of everything that remains if you
like our podcast you'll enjoy the audio
book version of that or if you want the
book book or the ebook version
we'll send those to you as well Ryan
what time is it you know what time it is
it's time for the lightning round where
we answer your questions from Tick Tock
yes indeed you can follow the
minimalists on Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook and Twitter at the minimalist
now during the lightning round we each
have 60 seconds to answer your questions
with a short shareable less than 140
character response we put the text to
these minimal maxims in the show notes
over at the minimalists.com podcast so
you can copy and share our pithy answers
on social media if you'd like
hippo site has a question for us if
hoarding and being unable to let go of
things is a mental illness can an
obsession with letting go also be
considered a mental illness a lot of
people get really tied up with this
whole mental illness thing yeah as
though it's a bad thing and so we've
talked about this on a few of the most
recent episodes starting with the
Clutter Corps episode and what I was
talking about there Ryan before we get
into our 60-second pithy answers I was
simply trying to illustrate
a fact that hoarding is described by the
Mayo Clinic by NHS by the Cleveland
Clinic as a mental disorder that's not a
good thing or a bad thing it is an
illness it is a mental illness
you had a cold a couple weeks ago Ryan
you were ill that's not a bad thing I'm
not saying you're a bad person you did
something immoral well he might have
done something immoral to get that code
never
but the point is you had an illness if
anything it's to be compassionate for
someone else who has some sort of
illness Ryan and I were hoarders back in
our corporate days we were not
intentional about the things we brought
into our lives we were not intentional
about the things we held on to in fact
we cling tightly to those things I do
want to answer the question head on
though so give me 60 seconds Professor
Sean
Letting Go happens when the clinging
ceases
now hippocyte here says hey you know
what
you're saying that hoarding is a mental
illness but what if letting go
is that also a mental illness
and I would say no Letting Go by itself
is not a mental illness but the
inability to hold on to anything is
called spartanism and that is the
inverse of hoarding they both exist on
the OCD Spectrum
it is an illness it doesn't mean someone
is bad for having that illness if
anything I want to have compassion for
anyone who has an illness I don't want
to judge them and say how dare you have
this illness how dare you cling to these
things or how dare you keep letting go
with your spartanism no I want to get
curious about I want to understand
oh tell me more about that illness tell
me more about how you're struggling tell
me why you can't let go hmm
all right give me 60 seconds oh man you
were right on nice all right here we go
uh labels are helpful when they clarify
harmful when they shape your identity so
it's very helpful to have a label this
is a microphone this is a shirt if I try
to be a shirt my life is going to be
very different but the label of a shirt
helps me identify something so when it
comes to minimalism it's great to have
this label that helps you identify
something but when the label defines who
you are as a person like that's what
really starts to be a detriment so yes
letting go of too many things is a
mental illness that's spartanism holding
on to too many things an absorbent
amount of things that is also a mental
illness it's called hoarding minimalism
kind of helps us find that middle ground
and that's that's what labels should do
they should guide you not
compel you
I don't know they should I don't I don't
know they should guide you not not be
your identity you are a shirt thanks
[Laughter]
we'll check in with our patreon live
stream here in a moment so drop your
questions and comments in the chat but
first real quick for right here right
now here's one thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalist did you know
that the minimalists have a hundred free
local meetup groups technically 101
because we also have an online City if
none of these groups are around you so
nine years ago Ryan we went all over the
world eight different countries a
hundred different cities and we had this
long tour in each City we eventually
left behind
a Meetup Group in every city so you
could connect with open-minded
dogma-free people who are also
decluttering their lives in various ways
it can be material clutter it could be
career clutter digital clutter as we've
talked about
but
we have uh a hundred different groups
you can head on over to
minimalist.org you find the city that's
closest to you they meet in person
regularly or you go to the online City
in the Ryan we have uh a few you have
like themes each month that people are
talking about you want to talk about
some of the themes coming up over the
next few months yeah so uh we started
doing this last year we just came up
with different topics for each month to
kind of give people an idea of what um
they're going to get a taste of when
they show up to these these
minimalist.org meetup groups so uh March
we've got sentimental items in April
we've got relationship clutter in May
we've got environmental clutter so what
these communities really are about is uh
it's about supporting one another it's
about
um giving some time and attention to
things uh that matter and I would love
to say that they are you know
like-minded but there's it's not
like-minded but it's definitely
open-minded and you know these this is a
result of people asking us how how can
we hang out with with other minimalists
talk we hang out with other people we
didn't have an answer to that but now we
have an answer so if you want to go hang
out with some open-minded people who are
practicing minimalism in their lives and
go over to minimalist.org and check out
if there's a meet up near you and a lot
of aspiring minimalists as well and so
it often starts with the topic of
discussion for that month maybe like in
April you're talking about relationship
clutter and that's where it starts but
all of a sudden you start to uncover all
these other areas of clutter my
relationship clutter has led me to buy
things I don't actually want so it's
creating more material clutter and that
material clutter is now creating
Financial clutter and you start
following all of these these different
paths and so it starts with some theme
some topic but that is just the signpost
through which you will travel to
whatever the destination is and you'll
travel there together minimalist.org to
find a city near you let's check in with
our patreon live stream Patron shout out
to you thank you for keeping the podcast
and YouTube Channel 100 advertisement
free what do you got for us from Alabama
we have a bunch of questions we'll start
with one from Kat is cheating is it
cheating to play the minimalism game in
February
you know it's it's funny because we get
asked a lot about is it cheating if I
count each paper clip individually is it
is it cheating yeah you know here's the
thing
um that is that is an idea for you to
use how you want
um there's no way to cheat if you're
cheating anyone and you're cheating
yourself so the question cat is does it
feel like you're cheating yourself if
you're doing it in February because you
are uh you know getting three days less
of the minimalism game
but you know if you want our blessing to
do it in February then cat you have our
blessing yeah yeah it's a shortcut it's
it's easy mode for the game so the
30-day minimalism game you can download
the free calendar by the way over at the
minimalists.com game and if you want to
do it or 28 days that's fine if you want
to do over 31 days we've had people who
keep going day 33 day 34 day 35. yeah
and it starts off really easy because it
gets you that momentum you need to start
letting go and so it's about getting rid
of one thing on day one to give you that
momentum for day two is two things then
three things on the third day four
things on the fourth day so forth and so
on starts off pretty easy but it gets
more difficult as the month progresses I
will say it's only cheating though if
you're also tidying up with Marie kondo
at the same time
did you see the latest about Marie kondo
or she have you seen it or tell me
should I not talk about it um no she uh
she basically you know kind of confessed
that now I think she has a kid now oh
wait he missed last week's podcast
episode oh so you talked about this on
last year we did a whole we did a whole
on the private podcast we did a whole
more about less segment okay Marie kondo
is messy but it was her who's saying
she's messy exactly yes yes okay so we
won't rehash it we'll check back in with
the live stream here in a bit but first
from Alabama what you got for us here's
a minimalist Insight from one of our
listeners
my name is Luke Pearson Las Vegas Nevada
uh I've had a comment about Fitness I'm
reading a book it's called starting
strength it's a very
simple way to exercise for people who go
to the gym is often confusing people who
like to go to the gym it's often hard to
minimalize your Fitness routine so I
started to read this book and it's
simple it may not be
it may not be easy but it is very simple
um and it's implemented a lot of things
in my life my back's more strong just
everything about me is stronger don't
really care about what I look like but I
feel stronger and I feel healthy
um you know and I just enjoy working out
but it was so difficult before but now
reading this book starting strength by
Mark ripito
um just hope that helps definitely if
you go to the gym a lot it will simplify
your life
all right y'all that's our minimal
episode for today we'll see you on
patreon for the full two hour maximal
edition of episode 380 which includes
answers to a bunch more questions like
how do I say no to material possessions
without sounding ungrateful my digital
clutter is far more difficult to
declutter than my physical clutter where
do I even start also got a million more
questions for the minimalists also this
week a private minimalist home tour you
get to see my wife's new she shed
so many posters of shirtless men
we also got a new amasset or trash it
segment here's a hint shots shots shots
I think we're calling this one a match a
massive or smash it really yeah we've
got an outstanding added value segment
for you three things that are adding
value to our lives right now and much
much much more of less and if you want
to hear all that check out the
minimalist private podcast at
patreon.com slash the minimalist or
click the link in the description to
subscribe and get your personal link so
that our weekly maximal episodes play in
your favorite podcast app you'll also
gain access to all of our private
podcast archives all of our archives all
the way back to episode zero zero one
and if you're still on the fence here's
a testimonial from one of our lovely
patreon subscribers Chris said and by
the way I asked him to make sure we
could talk about this one because it's
deep okay real quick he said Ryan when I
found minimalism through you guys it's
not an exaggeration to say that it saved
my life I've been battling depression
for years trying to find a way of living
that would help me I finally found it
through the work you and Joshua have
done so basically our private podcast
saved his life yeah dude you know what I
could hear that a million times and it
it's just it's amazing like the fact
that we have any opportunity to
add value to anyone's life especially to
this extent dude like that's that's
freaking amazing yeah
Alabama she grabbed the mic just to tear
up I'm not sure what what's going on
over there not emotional it's okay
uh Chris I'm really grateful thank you
so much I know it wasn't our podcast
that saved your life what saved your
life was your willingness to to tune in
not to us but tune into yourself and
understand the underlying issues here
stuff is not going to make your life
perfect getting rid of the stuff is not
going to make your life perfect
in fact it's not even going to make your
life better it's going to make room for
better understanding what it means to
live a meaningful life Wow thank you so
much Chris everyone else if you leave
here today with just one message let it
be this
love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks for listening y'all
see you next time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed or I bet that you'll
be fine without it